so the brains of Maga seem to be
breaking over this new Story related to
some classified documents that were left
behind at an office of then Vice
President Joe Biden now I have made
every effort and it hasn't been very
difficult to be consistent about this
story uh Donald Trump should have and is
it being investigated for his handling
of classified documents including taking
a whole bunch of them to his house and
then lying about where they are and then
avoiding returning them and all these
different things and Joe Biden should
likewise be investigated now the
circumstances of course are completely
different we're talking about a couple
about a dozen or so documents with Joe
Biden and we're talking about what
hundreds or more with Trump we're
talking about something with Joe Biden
where when his lawyers found out they
immediately notified the National
Archives it was the opposite with Trump
there is no evidence whatsoever that Joe
Biden asked or was even involved in
these documents remaining where they
were whereas there is widespread a
testimony that Donald Trump specifically
said take these documents down to
Mar-A-Lago there are no similarities but
I am consistent investigate everyone and
everything and see where it shakes out
right Wingers brains seem to have been
scrambled by this here is Ronnie Jackson
who says he believes these documents
were found as part of a conspiracy by
democrats to push Biden out before 2024.
and it could be happening here Jin is
that I've been saying for a long time
that the Democrats are going to have to
figure out a way to get rid of Joe Biden
they don't want this man to run for
president again he's a recipe for
disaster in the next presidential
election so I think you know a lot of
people thought it would be his cognitive
issue you know I thought so as well but
I thought well maybe they won't go down
there because that's admitting to fate
that they put this cognitively
incompetent man in a position like the
president of the United States I said
all along I thought maybe they would let
the hunter Biden thing blow up a little
bit but maybe this is what they're doing
maybe this is the first shot that
they're going to fire to try to get him
in a position where he ultimately has to
resign or at least has to decide that
he's not going to run again now the
reason this is very stupid is of course
number one there's no evidence of that
but number two it doesn't really make
sense because as I talked about at the
top of the show why is Joe Biden a
disaster in the sense that in polling
against Trump Biden is mostly winning
for 2024. unemployment is the lowest
it's been in 50 years inflation has come
down six months in a row wages are up
the idea that it's obviously a disaster
for Biden to run isn't borne out by the
facts now here's Alina Haba Trump's
lawyer who says what about her being
special prosecutor on Biden's boxes of
course there are no boxes we're talking
about 12 12 documents Alina do you think
this completely exonerates Trump from
the the Merrick Garland documents Witch
Hunt
I think so and I think that more
importantly we should oh by the way on
this exoneration thing they don't seem
to get that just because someone else is
being investigated for something it
doesn't mean you're exonerated it's sort
I use this analogy yesterday and it's so
simple but it's so so uh emblematic of
this
if I am accused of murder
and then someone else is accused of
murder I don't get to say I'm exonerated
because someone else is now being
investigated for murder that's the
argument they're making here and it's a
very silly argument point out one thing
very important Donald Trump was the
sitting president of the United States
had the ability to declassify the
presidential records act applied to him
Biden doesn't have that excuse he was
the vice president yes now he's the
sitting president but these are
documents that we're taking during the
Obama Administration they are in places
that are not secure he was a PR he was
not a president at the time he had no
right to them I saw an article today I
believe and and it said that he had the
presidential records incorrect he was a
vice president he's not afforded those
protections and he doesn't have the
ability to do so so I think that this
does help president Trump quite honestly
I don't think president Trump needed
help because I don't think he did
anything wrong we now by the way I I
know Alina Hab is an attorney
the research she says the presidential
records act doesn't apply to the vice
president I I believe it does the
research I've been able to find says
that the presidential records Act of
1978 governs both the President and Vice
President
maybe I'm misunderstanding that I don't
know we're cooperating as you know and
and that matter is underway but they
weren't cooperating they have to show
that they're going to treat everybody
the same and I would like to personally
offer to be the special prosecutor on
Biden's boxes because yeah there are no
boxes because we're talking about 12
documents that were immediately uh told
the National Archives were immediately
notified by Biden's lawyers lastly
here's Claudia Tenney saying that
Biden's the biggest liar in American
politics she may be forgetting about a
guy who told like 14 000 lies during his
presidency I give her credit because to
be the press secretary and have to lie
for the biggest liar in modern politics
is quite an extraordinary obligation and
job I give her I mean what's she gonna
say he may not even know where they are
but look we look I give her credit
because so that's a republican
congresswoman Claudia Tenney now the
story is Biden is the biggest liar that
is out there their brain remains have
been scrambled and it's very very easy
to be consistent on this we say oh
anytime there's a question about
documents and presidents or former
presidents or vice presidents
investigate it and then go where the
facts take you what we know about the
facts of the Biden situation and the
Trump situation
are so dramatically different that it's
laughable to suggest there is even any
similarity but again investigate
everyone Hunter Biden investigate Hunter
Biden it's just not an issue for the
House of Representatives since it has
nothing whatsoever to do with politics
or the Biden Administration but if
Hunter Biden broke some law
with law enforcement investigate them
it's a we this isn't about protecting
Democrats it's about having some kind of
consistent standard about what we
consider to be wrongdoing as many people
know I'm a white ale type of guy when it
comes to beer and even for those of us
who drink responsibly like me sometimes
you still feel it the next day and it
can slow you down especially when you
start to get up there in the years like
me check out our sponsor zebiotics which
is a probiotic drink that breaks down
the byproduct of alcohol responsible for
those rough mornings after drinking all
you do is drink a tiny bottle of
zebiotics before you have alcohol next
day you'll feel refreshed and ready to
go the way it works is when you drink a
toxic byproduct builds up in your gut
and that's what causes you to feel bad
the next day zibiotics produces an
enzyme to break down that byproduct and
zibiotics stands by their product 100 if
it doesn't work for you you get all your
money back no questions asked remember
we're talking about drinking responsibly
here I can't more highly prioritize
getting a good night's sleep zibiotics
is for responsible drinkers who just
want to get the most out of the next day
go to zebiotics.com Pacman get fifteen
percent off your first order with the
code Pacman the link is down below